Dave's mom is now stepping into the
spotlight her name is Virginia Hanlon
grow she's sharing personal stories
about her son's rise to stardom
she spoke with mothers of more than a
dozen music icons including Pharrell
Williams Kelly Clarkson Miranda Lambert
dr. Dre Josh Groban her new book it's
called from cradle to stage stories from
the mothers who rocked and raised rock
stars great title to Nora now we're
talking about you Virginia Helen Grohl
and Dave Grohl join us both at the table
welcome to you votes yeah what mother
thank you so much you thank you love
eating you we're so glad you're here
Dave you wrote the foreword to your
mom's book you said every musician
remembers the first lesson where
epiphany music is no longer just to
sound and for you 1975
front seat of the Ford Maverick you and
Virginia girl what happened we were on
our way to the lake on a summer day and
we were listening to the AM radio which
we always had and Carly Simon's you're
so vain came on the radio and my mother
I always sang together in the car and
when the chorus came I want to hear Mick
Jagger you know he sings on the song and
so first they share the line and then
there's a line where they split in the
harmony right and so so Carly Simon
sings I bet you think this song is about
you don't you and my mother started
singing Mick Jagger's on so she started
singing don't you don't you don't you
see and so I that right then I realized
that two notes sung together like that
create harmony and and that creates a
chord and so from that moment on every
song I heard I was searching for harmony
and you said I want to do that I started
my listening to music not just hearing
it I started listening to easier because
when you talked to all the moms Virginia
every mother seemed to have a story like
that you saw a lot of similarities with
the mothers yes and their kids that it
was unstoppable like what and they were
tuned in in a different way they they
heard sounds that Dre heard the 70s
music and he heard every instrument and
every tone and everything and then he
you know what he did later was just put
them all together what happened for the
kids to them always can
assistant Li write this down okay 12 to
13 and they just declared at that point
music is my life don't expect me to do
anything else and you're gonna capture
cold what's a mother to do yes it makes
perfect sense I mean you know my mother
we've been closed my until she's very
cool she's always the cool she was the
cool teacher at her high school she's a
public school teacher for 35 years so
she was the coolest was she's so cool
that when you began sending her taped of
your music she loved it I don't know if
she ever like yeah baby I know she was
always very supportive but that was a
thing my mother sang when she was young
she was in acapella groups the three
bells yes Bell and so there was always
music around the house you know I'd
listen to crazy punk rock music but then
we would listen to the Manhattan
Transfer together and then I would
listen to David Bowie Neil Young but we
would listen to Candide together and so
she took me to jazz clubs in Washington
DC and so it was always very musical yes
yeah once go ahead you know what's
interesting to me is I have a lot of
friends have been very successful in
other businesses in other professions
they would trade it all in if they could
be a rock star I agree not a bad gig I
beg you I've had worse jobs about that
you're on stage and you look for as long
as you're I can see thousands of people
singing your song and really loving you
yeah it's funny because when you write
music you're writing something that you
truly deeply believe or feel on - like a
napkin in your garage and then you sing
it into a microphone and you wind up at
a stadium full of 80,000 people where
they're singing it back to you and
there's something about that that that
bond when that many people join together
in the chorus it's the most powerful few
that's different that's a great
satisfaction of being live for the
audience absolutely really brings people
and that's my favorite thing when I'm
watching from the side of the stage
right behind the curtain
I watched the audience and I watched
that energy
fer and I see them moving and bouncing
and smiling holding up their signs and
and singing along you said your life has
changed the first time you heard a crowd
scream for your son I also say this a
lot of the mothers say that they had the
conversation that's where the kids as
Dave came to you and said I want to drop
out of school that that happens in a lot
of these rocks yes people yes because
they they suddenly well not suddenly but
over long period school is very
difficult no one is assisting them in
their love of this thing they're
obsessed with you said that's when he
had rights that you didn't fight for
David's cool I could never make that
different for him and I was in the
school I was a part of that whole system
but it just they had nothing for him
everyone liked him he got along with the
teachers would it have been different if
you didn't have the mom you had so
absolutely no question you know I think
that from the age of maybe 9 or 10 when
I started playing music had I I was so
obsessed with it it became the puzzle
where I just wanted to figure out the
Beatle song or the Led Zeppelin song or
I spent most of my time in front of a
record player with a guitar in my hand
had I had a parent that said get ya pick
up your book pick up your bow to be an
accountant yeah I mean yeah doctor you
know ya know you know what else is cool
Charlie she writes in the book one of
the best events that you like is the
Kennedy Center Honors oh yes did you get
to meet so many people and she loved it
there's a reason Franklin look Charlie
Rose just walk by that was a moment yes
yes you talk about the people that get
to me a letter in the glam of this all
right well I got to meet President Obama
at a night when well I have a photograph
and it records this I should have
brought it and it's me with my three
favorite men in the world
President Obama Paul McCartney and my
son
and me right yeah it was it was a pretty
good night this is wonderful and it's
nice that it comes right before Mother's
Day a reminder to about mothers
fostering their their children's passion
perfect timing terribly to you and what
show do you watch every morning well I
watch CBS this morning faithfully yes
all right going got another book so I
can get back look at your role there is
Charlie Rose yeah there is from cradle
to stage is on sale now